May 2015
Italian astronaut samantha cristoforetti
uploads a strange photograph she's taken
from the International Space Station a
star spangled milky way that isn't out
in space it's on the surface of the
earth so what we're looking at here is
an image that looks like a long strip of
lots of bright lights you think to
yourself where on earth is that whatever
this phenomena is it's massive the
gathering of the strange lights has
provoked wild speculation of
unidentified craft in the South Seas but
there are no reports of UFO sightings in
the area the NASA images also posed a
puzzle if you look at the satellite
images over a period of a few days you
can see that the lights actually move
around could the lights be coming from
mysterious craft after all
when investigators map the coordinates
onto local charts they realized the
lights form a pattern that exactly
matches the territorial waters of the
Falkland Islands this is the smoking gun
this shows us that we're looking at a
human operation on the ocean's surface
the only thing that it can be are ships
with lights the only thing that they can
be doing is fishing
the bright lights are part of a
high-tech fishing method that guarantees
an enormous catch at night if you shine
bright lights certain species will be
attracted to the surface the plankton
comes to the surface the smaller fish go
after the plankton the larger fish go
after the smaller fish the squid go
after the even larger fish sounds
convincing but there are many hundreds
of Lights out there and only 100
licenses per year are issued to fish
these waters there are far more lights
than you would imagine for those
licenses so we've got hundreds if not
thousands of unlicensed unregulated
fishermen out there just stripping the
ocean of fish completely illegally
illegal fishing in this area is big
business one night's catch of squid can
net up to 72 thousand dollars these
people could be taking 300,000 tons of
illegal fish from the oceans every
single year in March 2016 to illegal
fishing boats were caught in the area
one was sunk without Christopher Eddie's
photograph the enormous illegal
enterprise might never have been
discovered